the test of a nation's values is not how
we treat those who are law-abiding and
easy to like it's how we treat those
whose actions we abhor so a treatment of
Shamima Begum to other so-called Isis
Brides and the sex British children they
have between them shows that we are a
nation that is failing instead of
recognizing these women as cult victims
or terrorists who need to be processed
through our criminal justice system as
brits entitled to legal protection and
as parents of British children we have
conducted policy by tabloid headline now
that Begum's three-week-old baby Jarrah
has tragically died even the most
bloodthirsty among us who called a short
time ago for Begum to be left to rot in
a refugee camp are now showing a change
of heart this was a death we could have
prevented and we know it instead as we
celebrated International Women's Day for
the right type of law-abiding inspiring
ideologically attractive women we showed
just how limited our principles are for
women like these and for me that makes
all our celebrations ring hollow so when
you say where women like these you're
referring to women who actually think
that killing children in arenas is
somehow justified that's what we're
talking about when we say we're dealing
with women like we're talking about
people like shemune Vega who as a child
was groomed by a cult and and has now
put herself in a situation where she may
have committed as a 19 year old adult
sits there and comfortably states that
she stands by the decisions that she's
made and is comfortable with it so my
point is whilst you're presenting this
person as an absolute victim that I
should be dashing over to collect and
hug and all the rest of it and bring
back is now how I can endure that in my
intro Michelle you're not hear me saying
that they could be terrorists who should
be processed as such by the criminal
justice
yes but the justice system that we have
is currently not fit for purpose when it
comes to these cases hence we have a
variety of jihadis or people that have
gone over to learn the first place
wandering the streets
what I would say is firstly it would
make me sound callous if I wasn't to
acknowledge the fact that it's tragic
that an innocent baby has died
nobody would wish for that no matter
what the parents have done no baby
deserves that sir
you know that's terrible but ultimately
this is a lady who put herself in that
situation who chose to be in that
situation and even we'll see a clip I'm
sure very soon when when the question
was put to her would you allow your
child to be taken away ie brought to
safety the answer was no have you ever
interviewed someone who has been in a
cult or green by a cult Michelle I have
not because I have completely different
kind of cult totally different
circumstances but when I saw that
interview the Shamima bago
monotone voice her inability to make eye
contact her complete detachment from
reality watch her I have to say I feel a
lot of similarities yeah that's what
[ __ ] Shamima Begum was worried about her
son and her family said they wanted to
bring him to Britain although it wasn't
something she favored would you be
prepared to let the Sun go to the UK he
would stay with you so she didn't even
want her own child so we brought back to
safety here but my point is that I'll
bring you magic my point is they're
around 850 people who went from Britain
to join Isis who've come back to the UK
right about half of them I believe have
been put through the criminal justice
system or some kind of demonic elation
process almost none have been stripped
of their British citizenship this is a
girl who went as a child who was
stripped of her British nationality
because of public outrage following that
interview we don't know if she has the
mentality of someone green by a cult we
don't know if she's committed offenses
because she's not been tried
she hasn't been through the rule of law
processes we claim define us as a
country just because people don't like
her that this is what's happened to her
in the consequence I believe is that her
child has now died and I just want to
put them bring you in my Jeep read the
letter her family sent to the Home
Office
it's big and requests this
reconsideration as an act of mercy on
the basis of the following new
information namely the death of her
newborn son it is extremely unlikely
that Shamima will be in a fit state to
make any rational decisions as far as we
are aware the
government did not ask for the views of
nor consult with the government of
Bangladesh on whether Shamima held dual
nationality before the decision
depriving citizenship you will
appreciate there are immediate fears for
sure meemers health and safety and the
matter is urgent this is a 19 order
teenager who has lost three children in
short space of time who is under fear
for her life who is British and who we
have essentially left in violation of
domestic and I'm sorry magic because I'm
really interested in what you've got to
say as well but I just want to be clear
this child very sadly died because of
the choices his mother made nothing more
so can I just say that I think this is a
bit of a red herring this entire angle
that's being debated right now I think
it's less helpful though relevant to
talk about whether she has been groomed
whether we hate her like her feel sorry
for her it's relevant but less helpful
to this particular conversation in my
view because I think what's more
relevant is the legal precedent that
could or could not be set from stripping
citizenships and whether that creates a
two-tier citizenship in this country
that's point number one and I think that
should concern us more because of its
potential long-term implications legally
and also for community relations in this
country between those who have dual
citizenship and those who don't the
second point that I think really does
like a hot knife through the butter get
to the point here is actually less so
again about whether we like or not but
about whether we demand the right from
other countries to deport terrorists
that that have come from those countries
that are here in this country like we
did with Abu Qatada
like we did with our Omar Bakri Mohammed
like we did with the other hams of the
hook-hand we got rid of them because
they weren't born here they came from
elsewhere and the same voices that
demanded getting rid of them now in a
bit of a contradiction doesn't want to
take responsibility for our own born and
raised terrorists who've gone to other
countries we want to send them back hold
on Michele you guys had a long time
right and there's only one consistent
answer here which is either we deport
our foreign terrorists to other
countries and expect ask to come back
here or we don't deport ours that are
here with us and therefore don't take
ours back from over there either Nick
let's hear what the Home Secretary Sajid
Javid said about this in the House of
Commons I don't want any more children
brought into a war zone
because their parents think that they
will automatically bailed out no matter
what the risk but the UK is doing all we
can to help innocent people caught up in
this conflict the death of any British
child even even those Charles are
children born to a foreign terrorist
fighter of course it is a tragedy but
the only person responsible for the
death of that child is the foreign
terrorist fighter after you want to
bring her back and put us through the
British judicial system were you gonna
charge her with she's not a foreign
terrorist fighter she's British you want
to bring her back and put us through the
British judicial system what are you
gonna charge her with has there been an
invest I am NOT I haven't done the
investigation what you gonna charge her
with it depends what Michelle said Pitt
State is not to just decide you absolve
yourself of the problem is we have no
laws to try her we should go where this
government has failed and previous
governments is when these young people
started flocking off to Syria to join
Isis that is when they needed to impose
laws and they make it absolutely plain
if you want to run off that's fine you
will be brought back and you will go to
jail there is no law there's no law here
such a Javid saying that the British
government has a responsibility to help
innocent British people that is not how
nationality works you have a
responsibility to British criminals as
much as you have two innocent British
people and magic dangerous precedent
from work has been called insufficient
by the policy exchange and there is a
nice serious move which I think Sajid
Javid has looked at to bring back the
charge of treason the crime of treason
into the rulebook because the sentencing
guidelines and the and the justice
system are inadequate with the current
situation which is that you have
british-born citizens cooperating with a
non-state aggressor so what they need to
do is introduce the the crime of treason
again for people who feel like you're
watching the pledge on Sky News and up
next I'm celebrating the big three Earth
[Music]